Ngày 3 mốt tháng 5 năm, hành hủ trăm 25 vừa qua đã sẻ ra vụ việc hành hôm nhân viên ít tế tại khoa cấp cứu,
bình viện hiểu nghĩ đã khoang nghe ăn, người mất ăn nình chật tự, ăn hưởng tư cực đến công tác hảm bệ,
chứ bệ ăn toàn của vì bệnh và nhân viên ít tế.
Cô quan lý khám, chứ bệnh, bộ ít tế, đên nghĩ tình nghĩ ăn tăng cơ, bảo đảm ăn nình,
ăn toàn bệnh viện sau sự việc mô nhân viên ít tế bị hành hôm tại bệnh viện hiểu nghĩ đã khoang nghe ăn.
Đên nghĩ đồng chỉ chẳng văn phòng ui bán nhân dân tình nghĩ ăn bảo cao đồng chỉ chủ tịch ui bán nhân dân tình hình chương chỉ đạo cơ quan thực thi pháp lật của địa phương điều tra làm sõ vụ việc.
Sự liên nghiêm mình theo quy định của pháp lật. Ngành ít tế tăng cơ bảo đảm ăn nình, chật tự tại cơ sự khám bệnh,
chứ bệnh tục Trung có giải pháp định ăn trạc, hạn chế tự đà các chứ vực mất ăn nình.
Chật tự, trong đó có thiết lập hiện thống 3 xác và cạnh báo quy cửa với mất ăn nình,
chật tự và thực hiện các giải pháp theo lật khám bệnh, chứ bệnh số 1 năm 2020, khuôn trăm 2 mi ba khuy hết 1 năm.
Tự hiện các văn bản chỉ đạo của bộ ý tế về việc bảo đảm ăn ninh, ăn toàn và chật tự cơ sự khám bệnh, chứ bệnh.